la vie la vie est un défi à relever un
bonheur a mérité une aventure à tenter
ces mots de mère teresa prennent tout
leur sens au travers de mon existence
qui dans cette salle a déjà eu du mal à
trouver sa passion c'est pourquoi il
existe le pourquoi de son existence
c'est qu'il anime qui dans cette salle
qui merci
afin de découvrir votre vraie
personnalité il faille que vous laissiez
cet événement arrivé dans vos vies ou
dans votre vie des événements qui vous
feront sortir de votre zone de confort
afin que vous découvrez enfin qui vous
est en réalité votre vraie personnalité
des expériences j'en ai vécu et ce soir
je ne pense pas avoir le courage ni la
force de vous compter mon histoire
alors je vous contre l histoire de rita
reatard cette jeune fille là qui a vécu
une histoire similaire à la mienne est
arrivé à l'intérieur du pays avec ses
parents elle vient d'une famille très
modeste
elle était la risée de tous parce
qu'elle était un garçon manqué elle
avait son vélo elle était première de la
classe les gars on n'aime pas ça et dieu
merci elle obtient son bac elle vient
abijan prix avant son bac abijan cette
ville où seuls les audacieux réussissent
à tirer leur épingle du jeu parce que
quand tu n'as rien visant tu n'es rien
aux biens
émérite a eu la chance d'être dans un
quartier huppé de la place l'une de ses
tantes
elle vivait la vie de louga vous voyez
un peu le la transformation le
changement on l'a déposé à l'université
elle avait 5000 ou 10000 francs non
seulement tu déposes médecin mais loin
des 10000 fois que manger donc un moyen
au panier celle qui invitait ses amis
elle pensait que ça allait durer
peut-être tout allait bien
elle était la fille chérie de sa tante
jusqu'à ce qu'il joue les soeurs de la
tante viennent à la maison elles
commencèrent à lui mettre des bâtons
dans les roues afin que la tante déteste
sa petite-fille méritas s'est dit
qu'elle est la poussée étude qu'elle a
l'effet field fille de ça et là la voix
son master et elle a la voix du travail
afin d'aider ses parents mais un jour
alors qu il était 19h30
rita est allé à la boutique insultes et
des biscuits pour les petits frères et
au retour un événement sur 20 à la
maison la tante fut cambriolé et battu 5
millions fut emporté et rita qui entrent
dans la maison tout le monde la regarde
avec des yeux hagards
elle ne comprenait pas ce qui se passait
5 millions fut volé le lendemain
évidemment la police était là et elle
fut interrogé évidemment les soeurs de
la tante l'accusèrent d'être de mèche
avec ses cambrioleurs là et le même jour
à 20h elles ont juste demandé de libérer
la maison 1 20 heures du soir
qu'auriez vous fait
et éprouvent herti elle n'avait pas
d'amis intimes il a su personne à qui
elle a pensé c'est d'appeler un dragueur
vous imaginez la dague et pendant deux
ans tout de suite l'est la gare et le
compteur devant la porte
ils ont embarqué il avait une maisons
baillées parce que c'était un gendarme
et donc il vivait seul c'est elle qui
l'avait envahi dans son espace
il n'avait rien demandé rita a vécu deux
semaines de traumatismes puis celle de
semaine de chantage sexuel deux semaines
de souffrance
c'était ça soit il veut son corps où
elle ne mangeait pas
deux semaines
elle a préféré préserver sa dignité
parce que c'est tout ce qui lui restait
alors à se poser deux questions la
pauvreté est elle une fatalité
le fait que mes parents soient pauvres
était synonyme du fait que je serai
misérable tout au long de ma vie où que
je sois obligé de me livrer à des hommes
justes pour pouvoir réussir je vous
conte cette histoire par dans le bas
dans le but ce que vous jugiez sa
décision pas je vous conte cette
histoire a car quelque part dans une
cité universitaire
quelque part dans votre entourage et
peut-être même dans cette salle une
fillette au bout du gouffre mais tout ce
qu'elle à vous montrer ce son sourire
car nos histoires personnelles sont
difficiles à relater elle se retrouvait
dans un amphithéâtre et elle a eu le
courage l'audace d'expliquer ça à
quelqu'un qui par la grâce de dieu lui a
donnée nous sommes en cité universitaire
mon histoire est similaire à celle de
rita mais il fut un moment où j'ai
tellement souffert que j'ai j'ai promis
à dieu que si tu me réussissent à le
faire sortir de cette impasse
je te promets que générer toutes les
filles a fait qu'aucune d'entre elles ne
vivent la même situation
aucune d'après aucune d'entre elles
et un jour pendant que j'étais en cité
universitaire j'avais deux mille francs
et collèges et parcourait les images sur
facebook et j'ai vu l'image d'un petit
atteint d'une tumeur au cerveau et la
tumeur avait tellement détruit son
visage que cela paraît irréel ça faisait
trois mois que ça se promenait sur
facebook
alors j'ai appelé le contact jeudi au
quai halot bonjour je suis étudiante et
j'ai vu la photo du petit qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire
idiot km nous sommes à fresco notre fils
il a besoin des milieux aussi sommé d'y
jeter 10 mai 2011 donc d'accord dont je
suis allé à fresco le lendemain et je
suis allé voir le p tit j'ai eu la
chance de fascistes de co2 jean-patrick
et oman donc il m'avait donné une
certaine visibilité dont je me suis dit
pourquoi prendre le pouvoir ne pas
prendre des photos avec le p tit et
postés sur les réseaux sociaux on ne
sait jamais je ne sais pas sur quoi je
comptais mais comme oscar wilde m le dis
là essayez toujours de viser la lune car
en cas d'échec on atterrit toujours dans
les étoiles
quand je me suis dit même si j'ai pas
assez d'argent pour l'aider au moins
j'aurai essayé et donc je suis allé j'ai
appris la photo et j'étais étonné par le
nombre de partages plus de 1000
partagent au moins de deux semaines j'ai
reçu 600 mille francs
les personnes qui ne me connaissaient
pas ils mehsud mais mon voile a zoo pour
ça j'ai jamais compris
et puis dit si tu ne fais pas dieu te
vois je prends
et deux semaines après il ya un groupe
de personnes qui m'ont appelé
alors c'est le petit qui l'a donc aussi
à fresco avec la maman et de semaine
après y avait un groupe de personnes qui
m'ont contacté mondiaux que vous avez
vous avez combien j'ai déjà eu six ans
mais il dit au canda compléter l'agencé
millions 600 mille père et l'enfant
[Applaudissements]
et c'est eux laufon fut opéré
aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous parle
ça fait un an
il est sûrement en train de subir sa
deuxième opération parce que je pense
que ça commençait à 14 heures suite à
cela j'ai compris que peu importe les
difficultés que nous traversons nous
avons la possibilité d'impact et la vie
de quelqu'un d'autre
souvent nous pensons que nous sommes les
plus misérables au monde alors qu'on a
la possibilité avec nos données internet
eyes dono avec nos moyens de bord on a
la possibilité de changer quelque chose
dans la vie de quelqu'un
suite à cela tout ce qui venait à monter
que du positif
moi la fille voilà qui s'est dévoué il a
tout de suite quelqu'un a décidé de
m'offrir un stage à la banque mondiale
quelqu'un qui n'était pas de ma famille
et qui n'est pas de ma famille
l'alizé de mme aubry ce stage à la
banque mondiale qui jamais touché assez
d'argent comme star arrosoirs c'était
extraordinaire et j'ai dit dieu je
t'avais dit un jour que si tu réussis ça
me fait sortir de cette impasse
j'allais aider toutes les filles alors
j'ai donc investi dans l'aviculture afin
de lancer mon ong
vous venez en aide aux jeunes filles
dont l'âge varie entre 5 ans et 18 ans
mono ngc y voit un w à et power women in
africa danse et l'autonomisation de la
jeune fille africaine
après ça j'ai j'ai échoué cette fois aux
ja lee et la sino une fois c'est passé
il fallait aux états unis pour la
première fois peut pas dire qu'on va
faire la nature compense arnaud et je
suis encore à l'oeil n'est pas unie et
suite à ces expériences là j'ai compris
trois choses
trois choses 1
peu importe les difficultés que vous
traversez essayait toujours de voir le
côté positif car au bout du tunnel
vous découvrirez votre vraie
personnalité
ces événements vous aideront à sortir
devant votre zone de confort et vous
serez ce pour quoi vous existez cela va
révéler votre vraie personnalité
2 la force de la pensée
d'autres personnes appelleront cela la
loi d'attraction
j'ai pensé fortement j'ai rêvé d'avoir
une organisation afin d'aider les filles
mes étudiantes
je me disais comment cela peut être
possible mais j'ai tellement pensé à ça
tellement rêvé à cela que ça s'est
réalisé
la nature a tous réunis pour que ce soit
cela se réalise alors croyez fermement
en votre rêve
il peut devenir réalité mais les
américains disent pote yamani way home
of his vous devez joindre l'acte à la
parole il ne suffit pas de dire mais
vous devez agir pour que cela soit
possible
j'ai tellement pensé à y voit
aujourd'hui i oi aide plus de 60 filles
nous les aidons financièrement comme
sicot logiquement nous travaillons dans
un système de parrainage et de mentorat
aujourd'hui nous les formons aurait six
classes nous les formons avec un respect
de l'environnement nous les formons en
informatique
nous les formons un anglais nous avons
comme parthenay l'ambassade l'université
de l'atlantique et ça a juste été
possible parce que il ya eu quelques qui
a crû fortement ce projet je suis encore
étudiant en master 2 d'anglais je suis
pas en quoi arriver comme on le dit mais
ça c'est fait 2018
ça c'est fait
[Applaudissements]
le troisième élément que vous que vous
devez faire peut-être comme moi passer
votre vie à aider les autres la nature
n'est pas injuste vous récolterez le
fruit quel que soit le temps que cela
prendra
vous ne mourrez jamais pauvre car la
vraie richesse pour moi n'est ni la
finance ni le matériel dont nous
disposons la vraie richesse pour moi
c'est l'empreinte indélébile que nous
laissons dans la vie d'autrui qui bien
deux fois transforme positivement leur
existence alors aider les autres il est
si dieu agit en votre faveur
je suis si c'est bintou président de
l'om jean loi appelez-moi bini la
michelle obama l'afrique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]